Speaker 1: I have some incredible video for
you today. It would be funny if it weren't
so scary. CNN's Jim Acosta. While the NRA
convention was happening in Houston, Texas,
in the same state where 72 hours earlier we had
this horrific shooting in Duvall de Texas. CNN's
Jim Acosta interviewed a board member of the
National Rifle Association. That board member
is a Republican judge named Philip Journey, also
a former Kansas state senator. Jim Acosta asked,
why should an 18 year old be able to have an
AR 15? Why does an 18 year old need an AR 15?
And again, it would be hilarious if it
weren't for the fact that these people and
this organization were so powerful. Take a look
at this historic implosion on live television.
Speaker 2: With these mass shootings,
it keeps coming back to the
it keeps coming back to the AR 15 and similar
models. Why do people need an AR 15 anyway?
You know, it's just a semiautomatic rifle. I
mean, you know, if you want to be prejudiced
about the way it looks. But I was aware of what
happened to the 94 semiautomatic firearms ban.
And there were rifles of similar function
that just didn't look as ugly. They weren't
black guns like a mini 14. Ruger mini 14.
Speaker 1: So I, I can't help but mention
this talking point about there's prejudice against
certain prejudice against certain weapons based on
how they look. They want to almost make it like
it's a form of racism. Like you're judging things
by their cover and that you're prejudiced. If you
look at a weapon and say, that's a bad weapon,
they want to use the same terms almost
as if it were a form of racism. This is
a concerted effort that they make to talk
about prejudice and discrimination against
firearms based on the way they look. Okay,
let's continue the meaningless word salad.
Speaker 2: And of course, the Ruger many
14 was appropriate at the age of 15 was not
if it had a bayonet leg or a vertical rear grip.
So they designed it. I do want to ask you about
the assault weapons ban, but, you know, on the
air, 15. How how is it that an 18 year old can
buy an AR 15 style rifle and have 1600 rounds
of ammo with him like we saw a new volley?
Well, it's they did not have any prior
convictions. He didn't have any prior
issues that would have kept him from purchasing
one. It's my understanding from the news
that he purchased it through a firearms
dealer. He passed the background check
because he didn't have any prior convictions.
Speaker 1: Now, of course, this is the problem. If
we did the things I suggested limit these firearms
to those 25 plus require more extensive training,
required two or three letters from adults in
the community saying, I have no issues with
this individual having firearms require
a mental health evaluation. Those things
would likely have at least made it
more difficult for these for this
individual to get these particular
firearms with this guy saying is
he got them because there was nothing in place
that stopped him. Right. Well, but that's the
problem. We need to put things in place.
Speaker 2: Right. But should an 18 year old
have an A or. That's how he bought it. Should
it be should an 18 year old have an AR 15?
What's he going to do? I don't know.
17 year old have one. And the Army
should have military they have military
training in the Army. This 18 year old
in Uvalde, he did not have military training.
He turned 18 and he went out, bought an AR 15.
Okay. And the fact is that these kinds of.
Speaker 1: Issues that you just call them, Ed.
Speaker 2: Are far more complicated than whether
we remove something from the public. These issues
and criminal genetics can't buy a beer. If you're
18, you can't buy a pack of Cigarets crime are
more complicated than the easy answer. Do you
want to know why politicians seems to go to gun
control? Because it doesn't cost them any money.
Speaker 1: Oh, God. Okay, so listen. Completely
humiliating. I mean, a complete and total
implosion. That being said, the pro-gun people do
have an easy answer, which this guy just missed.
I don't agree with this answer, but sometimes,
you know, when when you ask some of these folks
this exact question that Jim Acosta is asking,
sometimes they go, Jim, I don't need to defend
that. It's in the Constitution, period now. It's
lame. It ignores reality, but it is an answer
which is like, just because you don't like it,
Jim, doesn't mean it isn't in the Constitution.
It's not about why does an 18 year old need it?
We have a constitution and a right to bear
arms. Now, of course, the counter would be
limiting certain guns for certain people,
whether because of age or whatever. These are
not violations of the Second Amendment. So there
is there are rebuttals to the rebuttals for sure.
And this entire thing of your prejudice against
guns because of how they look, they want you
to think like it's racism. Now, one bonus here,
as you all may know, and we will look at later,
Donald Trump danced. He did his dance on stage
after speaking to the NRA three days after the
horrible shooting in Texas. Jim Acosta asked this
guy, this NRA board member, about Trump's dancing
and the guy just denies that it happened. And then
CNN puts it up on the screen alongside this guy
saying Trump didn't dance. And this is what we've
been talking about for a long time. It doesn't
matter if it's on video, they'll still deny stuff.
Speaker 2: And you already your group is holding
its convention in Houston where you are right
now, just a few days after the massacre. And
you've already we saw Donald Trump dancing on
stage at the end of his remarks. He was not
I was there. He was not dancing. How is
how any of this how is any of this at
all appropriate? We're showing it on stage
right now. He's doing a little jig there.
People are waving their NRA hats and so on. It's
the celebratory atmosphere right after a mass
shooting where all of these kids are gunned down.
How is that appropriate at? I think that what
you're doing is just telling part of the story
there, because at the beginning of his speech, he
did do a very memorable memorial for the victim.
Speaker 1: So first, he says Trump didn't dance.
And then when the video gets put on the screen,
he says, well, the dancing is only part of the
story. But. But you just said he didn't dance.
So which is it? These people are really sick.
Really, really sick. They are not a scourge,
as Trump pronounces it, but they are they are
really a scourge. And we're going to look at
what happened at the NRA convention after the
break. But we've got an uphill battle here, my
friends. I do want to announce we are going to
be doing our next David Pakman show member
town hall on June 14th at 6 p.m. Eastern.
It'll be streamed on the Pacman Live YouTube
channel only, and I hope you'll join me there